[موسيقى]
على مساحه اكثر من مليون متر مربع يمتد
معرض رشيد كرامي الدولي صرح هندسي ومعمري
ضخم يحمل بصمه وتوقيع المهندس البرازيلي
العالمي اوسكارني
حدائق بلاسوار وبورك ومسرح عائم وبيت
ضيافه ومهبط للطائرات وقاعات بهندسه فريده
قوامها البطون المسلح
[موسيقى]
لماير اراد تحويل هذه المساحه الى مركز
استقطاب للمعارض العالميه غير ان الحرب
الاهليه واوضاع لبنان حاله دون ذلك واقتصر
العمل فيه على معارض محليه ومهرجانات
صغيره
هذه المعالم باقواسها وانحناءاتها
واشكالها الهندسيه تنفض عنها اليوم غبار
الاهمال ورواسب الاقتتال الداخلي ليعود
معرض رشيد كرامي الى الواجهه مع اعلان
اليونسكو وضعه على لائحه التراث العالمي
ويعيد معه عاصمه لبنان الثانيه الى
الواجهه
واذا كان المعرض سادس معلم لبناني يدرج
على لائحه اليونسكو بعد جبيل وصور وعنجر
ووادي قضيشه والارز الا انه الاول من صنف
العماره الحديثه هندسه وتنفيذا في الشرق
الاوسط والعالم العربي لصباح العربيه